let's talk about uh ritz man we're just
talking like how he's been here twice
and you know he's sold out each time and
he's kind of like
you know
on his way to doing big things in
himself i mean as like the guy who he
always credits you know like you saved
his life you know what i mean it's how
he always puts it and uh
you know he's like the the first
american guy you know what i mean out of
your camp to really
to really take off like that i mean how
proud are you with him and and what is
that like seeing him take off like [__]
man it's like uh
um
i knew it you know i knew that i knew
that he was uh
special it was like
[__] man i didn't understand why the
people around him didn't get it you know
but i knew that if all it was was just
mentioning his name
to to the right people to say hey man
check this dude out you know and
i knew that if i got him on the right
record where he could like
be himself which was box chevy of course
i thought he was black
when i heard black black chevy he is
black
yeah everybody thought he's black and he
is he's black
um
nah but um he uh he killed it and then
uh
he just stayed consistent he's one of
those people i believe that will always
be consistent you'll always get that
classic ritz
i mean i could say like
i'm not that way at all i'm sporadic i'm
very creatively um schizo
yeah like yeah you're gonna get
different styles you're gonna get
different things but with rich it's like
you're gonna if you like white jesus
revival then you will like the rest of
the [__] he puts out if you like white
jesus you will like him for the rest of
his life yeah probably you know
his music will just get more classic and
bigger yeah i mean [__] if um
he's i mean he's bound to [__] get a
hit you know so now they might i mean
the mike posters was was dope i thought
that could have taken off
you know well you never know man we got
to get some footage of uh blower
management right over there
that is newport making the bible belts
yeah we're making the bible bells
backstage
you gotta show us
this is homemade
fish bible belt
this is uh you know
basically as skateboarders coming up we
shoe straight straight
you know for belts and uh
but
we just came up with this [__] like we
wanted to enter you know like
to have the back of the belt
be thick so your the shoestring didn't
roll up into your jeans and [__]
but still have the tie in the front and
the steez so
the bible belt was born
and [__] we can't make them selling them
at the shows right in the house and if
you buy a belt you get to take a photo
with this guy and meet him
they sold out uh in 30 minutes
damn when we uh put them out tonight so
that's a good look um love story man
this is the second album that everyone
and i've been looking forward to it for
a very long time because you've you've
already had this album in the works
like this album and its name was already
planned right after like when you were
making radioactive it wasn't like you
came up with it after that the first
album yeah yeah this is something that
has been kind of yeah love story's been
in the works for a while you know
and you know i've since radioactive we
did
you know numerous freestyles we've done
like uh the m16 yeah the heart of dixie
we've done uh trump music returns uh
psycho white work with travis barker
we've uh
just put out black fall
so man i've been really working man
trying to uh
just stay at it and uh
stay inspired man you know in the
meantime because uh
it's like i'm sitting on like [__]
[__] the eye of the stove right now
with this love story [__] man i really
think it's
man i just think
i mean whatever people can [__]
listen to and think what they want to
think about it but i really love it well
like you just said
creatively you're kind of schizophrenic
and i feel like
a lot of like your og fans like i'm i'm
you know i've been [__] with you man
the first time i really heard you've
heard wolf on something was uh why i was
like i googled this [__] was the
mix up the medicine the hook
before you made your own version
yeah but a lot of people like you know
they just they hold you
the standard of trunk music
and uh trunk music returns definitely
for those fans that needed that that
yellow got it you know what i'm saying
but on the album
um
i guess creatively where do you think it
fits in with
with with women i don't know man i just
uh something maybe we haven't heard yet
or is it i think it's a lot of [__] that
people haven't heard um
well it's gonna be a lot of [__] that
i've done mixed in
you know
i think that i've um
you hear that
option kills it oh yeah
oh [__] so um yeah i think it's just i i
i don't expect um
i've kind of put out i'm not expecting
anything out of this album you know what
i'm saying as far as
people's reactions i'm just making sure
that i'm doing something that's pushing
me creatively
and i think people are going to really
[__] love that we're just talking um
on on the struggle record outlaw [__] at
the end you've
and seen not a lot of people knew that
you had a voice like that on the album
do you visit that place creatively
on love story uh yeah yeah a lot of
uh
a lot of singing
you know just [__] letting loose you
know
um
of course keeping mc [__] unlocked you
know making sure that
i'm trying to make it i'm trying to make
sure that all the styles are spoken for
but at some point
you got
people can't tie me down to a style they
just they got to let me live you know
what i'm saying like this is how it is
like i love
making music
but really i can't tie myself down i
don't think it's the people where where
it is i've tied myself down uh thinking
about what they what they're yeah what
they might think people's opinions
maybe the feedback so you know it's it's
all good man i think that this music uh
it's still
that's all i i love it so
we'll see man production wise i'm sure
you got super hot beats on there yeah i
will
yeah willpower's on there willpower did
a lot of the music we went to nashville
and zone the [__] out man and uh
now malay malay who uh he produced uh
frank ocean's last album oh [__] okay
me and malay we did record six years ago
actually that are gonna be on love story
oh [__] so
there's some [__] that i had been on
you know
what you know some people might not know
uh that before trump music i was on this
like you're already doing that
i i mean your previous tapes before
trump music when you're making a lot of
a classic
like rock [__] like i feel like the
people that caught onto drug music they
they hold you to that but you know
you're
like you said man you can't limit
yourself because you've been that artist
all the time right
yeah i think like
you know it is what it is trump music is
you know
i'm thankful for it you know i'm
thankful for what it's done for me uh
i do find it a little like
really like that's
what you think is like
super great and
which is great but
there's records on trump music that are
whatever like i don't give a [__] what
you say they're like just average as
[__] the only song that pops in my head
that was kind of like whatever was the
joint with diamond the lick the cap yeah
but i still like that
yeah i don't know
but i do got to give a shout out this is
totally off topic moves as we mentioned
super hot beats willpower the [__]
block chevy iv
when the beat just drops it's like the
hip-hop version of a metallica solo
yeah shout out to [__] willpower yeah
and how slept on was the slumden bridge
ep dude and now ed sheeran is like the
[__] man
man i i don't know what that was like
you can never put my finger on how [__]
gets slept on it was sewing if you were
to come out with that today now he's
like i mean back then he was big but now
he's you know
he's a [__] pop star now yeah i don't
know man i i really don't
i don't know i i guess people could just
for music fans they can go back and dig
on the catalog you know get that sunday
bridge ep four tracks [__] class
forgot we did that after radioactive
yeah that's right you've done a lot of
[__] after radioactive
you